yeah ever wish you had a list of
equipment and supplies for post
construction cleanup well I actually put
one together for you and you'll be able
to find it in the janitorial store in
the Donald library but here's the what I
did is I actually created a list of for
general cleaning you know this this here
is the equipment and supplies that you
would use on just about any type of post
instruction cleanup that you would do
you know you know all your knees an
extension ladder pull a stepladder of
some sort backpack or a vacuum you know
dustpan broom you know different things
like that there you know just all the
con con come items that you would use
trying to also eat the supplies you know
it's always good to have a tote for your
supplies because once this stuff is all
just you know handheld items so it's
good to have you know I listed some of
the chemicals that you would use you
know and some of the other supplies that
you might have to brush grout brush and
so on and so forth
also then what I did because I went
ahead and I did one for hard floor care
because in some of the cases when we're
doing post construction cleanup they're
gonna ask us to go ahead and strip VCT
tile and apply one or two coats of floor
finish so here I listed the types of
equipment that you may use so in most
cases maybe you're going to use a floor
machine either a rotary or cylindrical
you know that's just a personal
preference I like rotary I can do a much
more with that type of equipment and I
always have brush drives I use brushes I
don't buy any pads anymore then if
you're doing any searching the ceramic
tile and grout you know recommend that
you use a you know a 1200 PSI extractor
with an X X 15 one that's just the way
to go it's just a much much better
system to have I listed some of the
supplies on the other side here you know
for you
floor strippers neutral pH floor cleaner
razor knife knee pads floor finish etc I
left room for you to expand this to four
items at
my thought of I am putting also here for
carpet care
you know sometimes majority time
probably will do is they'll ask you to
do some carpet spotting but there I had
a job one time where they didn't do put
any protector on the carpet and then it
got trashed and they hired us to go
ahead and clean the carpet so I brought
in our hot water extractor you know did
a hot water extraction on it and dry it
and everything and it looked great so
some of the things like I listed your
foot equipment is you know the three
gallon pump up sprayer you know those
are just great for applying your your
neutralizers and your pre sprays you
know some of your supplies that you'd
have is obviously a carpet spotting kit
within that kit you can have the
different chemicals that you'll need for
spotting the carpet to remove whatever
it might be
there'll be a tapping brush in there
you'll find you should also have in your
carpet spying kit you know some kind of
carbon spider so it kind of walks you
through what you the steps that you want
to do for various types of stop spots
I've got window cleaning too so on this
side again I've got the equipment so you
know you may have a window cleaning
pocket you might use a five-gallon
bucket you might have a hip bucket on a
belt so for any of y'all set I have done
a lot of window window cleaning them
then I bought a stepladder and or a
extension ladder you know a hip bucket
on a belt is the way to go because now
you got all your tools right there on
your belt you'll be able have your t-bar
applicator and your squeegee and your
your sponges and your cloths and
everything on your belt some of the
other things that I put in here was the
t-bar applicator obviously extension
poles they're always handy then I put an
adjustable offset adapter so for for use
uh for those of you that don't know what
that is this is it this is an adapter
and what it does is it connects onto
your extension pole and this one here is
a longer then you have an actual swivel
you can adjust the
angle of this here to whatever angle
that you need for for when you're
washing and overhang or something like
that this here you're in a hall you're
going to go ahead and put your
applicator on there or your squeegee or
fixie clapper or some you know whatever
it is that you're that you're trying to
do but that's all this is it works great
so you should have these in your arsenal
if your window cleaning what I put on
the supply side was some of the you know
dish just soap that's probably one of
the best things I always used done dish
soap
you don't need no fancy window clean
solutions or anything like that
microfiber cloth chamois is sea foam
sponge you know for our steel wall hard
water remover you know and lint-free
gloves and microfiber pads now the
microfiber pads are for a telescopic
handle with a microfiber pad holder when
you're doing that oh let's say you got
two story windows or some that are kind
of kind of difficult to to wash where
you don't want to drip water on anything
well you're gonna use a telescopic
handle with a microfiber pad holder on
it and you're gonna attach a microfiber
pad to it that you pre sprayed with
glass cleaner and then you just raise
that up and take it to the window and
you clean the window that way so you
really minimize the amount of water that
you put on put on the pad and and apply
to the window and that's really the way
to go so I hope you found this helpful
if you liked the video go ahead and
subscribe down below and don't forget to
click on the like and share go ahead and
share this with other people and you
know I've got many more documents like
this
cleaning a section of the download
library of the janitorial store you'll
find proposals letters you know I'm
gonna put some brochures in there and
some marketing materials and different
things like that to you'll find helpful
and you know we'll keep on putting this
stuff in there and giving you some good
information to help you grow your
cleaning business until then have a good
one